[Musique]
je veux un 2008 car quatre mille
personnes qui couvre le marque donc le
marathon de chicago se passait devant
chez moi ils sont passés derrière chez
moi
et l'année suivante en 2009 pareil hein
2010 et fut décidé de faire comme eux
[Musique]
pieds nus là c'est une démarche un peu
différence parce que je me suis rendu
compte qu'en fait des humains nous
sommes des couleurs pour de nudistes
c'est à dire sans chaussures
nous sommes pas nés avec des chaussures
et pendant trois millions d'années des
ancêtres ont chassé il ce marché ils ont
migré pieds nus hier les européens où
descendra pas vos goûts vos assiettes
sont arrivés pieds nus au sud de
l'europe
j'imagine qu'ils s'étaient l'été parce
que si c'était l'idée de la fédé meet
you
[Musique]
pour moi courir des marathons pieds nus
donc je sais c'est une activité normale
que nos ancêtres exercées pour attraper
les animaux pour manger et que nous on
doit faire pour préserver notre santé
physique et mentale d'un coup un
objectif c'est de continuer d'exercer
cette activité naturelle de semaine
jusqu'à la fin de ma vie donc je
continue à courir des marathons en
france
dans le reste du monde qui est venu
juste pour montrer l'exemple aussi pour
essayer de faire en sorte que les gens
comprennent que comme moi c'est
l'activité normale d'ailleurs j'avais
tout le monde à me suivre ce site que 6
et que c'est mon t-shirt courait pieds
nus région la tendance